o agente comunitário de saúde
o herói invisível do sistema de saúde
brasileiro há sete anos atrás a gente
foi convidado para fazer um projeto para
controlar um profissional de campo que
não trabalhava muito não fazer suas
tarefas era mais ou menos consoante uma
tornozeleira eletrônica para saber se
está fazendo as visitas ou não era um
município pequeno 10 mil habitantes
longe da capital com pouca
infraestrutura difícil acesso à internet
é bem diferente do que a gente estava
acostumado no escritório ar condicionado
e wifi ou então fui pra campo calça
jeans pé na lama literalmente
eu queria entender o que estava
acontecendo e mais que isso eu queria
pegar no flagra aqueles que não faziam
visitas só que eu tinha uma grande
surpresa
primeiro eu percebi que o trabalho deles
não era tão fácil assim nem tão simples
sair de manhã cedo à unidade de saúde
com um monte de lixo embaixo do braço ea
pé
faça chuva ou faça sol para visitar
todas as famílias do seu bairro
algumas vezes bem recebidos outras nem
tanto e normalmente para visitar pessoas
em dificuldade ou com problemas de saúde
e conforme fui fazendo essas visitas com
eles eu comecei a perceber um valor que
não tinha percebido como por exemplo uma
visita
um casal de idosos aposentados com
diabetes
ele perguntava simplesmente aqueles
idosos tinham tomado remédios direitinho
só assim a medicação estava em dia uma
visita numa jovem de 19 anos
desempregada grávida com dois filhos
pequenos
perguntando pra ela está grávida estava
indo bem se ela tinha feito pré-natal se
as crianças estavam com vacina em dia ou
até mesmo uma visita é uma pessoa
aparentemente saudável de meia idade
só que ao chegar na casa ele ficou
sabendo que ela tinha acabado de
descobrir que tinha um câncer terminal
aqui a gente saúde não sabia se pedia
desculpa
se pedir licença embora da casa ou se
dava um abraço nessa pessoa enfim
histórias como essa face ao perceber o
quanto essas pessoas têm um carinho e
amor por essa profissão e mais que isso
que esse trabalho de formiguinha que
eles fazem lá no campo lá na ponta tem
impactado diretamente todo o sistema de
saúde e que essas formiguinhas na
verdade hoje são um grande exército da
saúde brasileira
são quase 300 mil profissionais
espalhados por todo o brasil
acompanhando mais de 120 milhões de
brasileiros
só que esse exército hoje está com a
minha de papel está sem munição na
verdade está sem ferramenta sem
conhecimentos em infraestrutura
foi então que a gente criou no primeiro
momento a comunidade chamada vida de
acesse e agente comunitário de saúde no
intuito de ser um canal de comunicação
com eles dá voz a reconhecimento da
palavra entender o que estava
acontecendo de verdade mais uma surpresa
que a gente teve é que 80% desses
acessos eram por smartphones e
dispositivos móveis
então a gente criou o aplicativo acesse
light um aplicativo 100% gratuito
preciso a gente saúde e que muito mais
do que digitar as fichas deles é
agilizar o processo burocrático é que
fosse uma ferramenta de empoderamento
que ajudasse o acompanhamento destas
famílias e no final de todas essas
visitas com o passar do tempo o que a
gente veio perceber é que aquele
município atrás de 10 mil habitantes
difícil acesso sem internet sem
infraestrutura
no fundo é o verdadeiro brasil e que a
exceção era o nosso escritório com ar
condicionado com a fae e com
infraestrutura para finalizar o que a
gente quer hoje é que esse aplicativo
essa solução principalmente essa
mensagem consiga chegar em todos os
agentes de saúde do brasil para que eles
consigam de fato cumprir o seu
verdadeiro propósito quer fazer o bem ea
cada dia acompanhar melhor essas
famílias que tanto precisa
obrigado
[Aplausos]